fox news alert president trump
saying the first coronavirus vaccines
could be delivered as early as next week
the promising news comes as one drug
maker prepares to go before the fda
and another one goes back to the drawing
board after an error in its clinical
trials
good morning i'm john scott
good morning john and i'm julie banderas
in for sandra smith president trump
making the announcement yesterday
during a special thanksgiving message to
u.s troops overseas the president
reiterating hope is on the horizon watch
during a pandemic the whole world is
suffering this tremendous pandemic not
just
us the world and it doesn't you wouldn't
know that to
listen to the news reports but the whole
world is
suffering and we're we're rounding the
curve the vaccines are being delivered
literally it'll start next week and the
week after
as fda regulators are set to review
pfizer's request for an emergency use
authorization
for its vaccine on december 10th
meanwhile astrazeneca is taking a big
step
backward in their push for a vaccine
after a dosing error
will likely force yet another clinical
trial casey stegall
is live in arlington texas what's the
issue with that astrazeneca vaccine
casey
john and julie good morning well
apparently scientists in the uk
that were working on the astrazeneca
vaccine
reporting that it was 90 percent
effective but as it turns out
the study participants were only given
half doses of the vaccine
and when they were given full doses its
efficacy dropped
to 62 percent so more studies will be
likely
meantime drug maker pfizer getting ready
for approval
and wide distribution of its vaccine
if it is approved doctors say this is
all
excellent excellent for the american
public
i think for the general public this is
still great news that those vaccines are
still on track
and that hopefully people should start
getting these doses
relatively soon or at least get offered
so i think that we are seeing the light
at the end of the tunnel
meantime new york governor andrew cuomo
responding to the supreme court's
decision this week striking down
his order restricting the size of
religious gatherings in certain parts of
the state
cuomo saying the court was partisan in
making that decision and said the
outcome was based
simply on three conservative judges
judges
that were nominated by president trump
julie john all right casey stegall
reporting from texas casey thank you